what is our mission secure Medina Wassel
my number one priority is to provide
hope to the people cuz right now they
don't have it all our bright thinking in
here is all for naught if we don't
control the crowd gets angry we gotta
keep the trio's keep their weapons down
you know little us on Lake and you
know why don't you clean it up a little
bitch is no such thing is
assalamualaikum ship it's their cultural
norm it's not to us it's important
professional polite vigilant this is my
first time going through this national
training center experience my goal for
my battalion is that did every lesson
that we learned here by time we leave at
the end about two weeks my troops are
confident in their ability everybody
knows what's at stake here they know
that we're gonna deploy they know that
we have to come together as a team we do
all the things that you do in Iraq and
it's it's tough but this is just a small
piece of you know what's to come for a
whole year
medina Wassel is the primary town in my
area of operations I think the criminal
element in the town has a grip on the
people i think by and large the people
are friendly and they want to live in
peace and prosperity but they're
intimidated by these thugs some towns
are friendlier than others some are
pro-us summer anti-us each has a
different problem set you can't script
every word we do plan events taking into
a fact of where their unit will be going
and what missions they think they're
going to be doing and what the unit will
expect to see when they get there
sectarian violence that's what IEDs and
all of those things that you see and
read about every day it's a thousand
little pieces that all form together to
make this one big training event happen
for this brigade combat team that when
it leaves here is gonna go to theatres
do it for real